[Music]
it's been
just over a week since the storming of
capitol hill
by pro trump mob and what a week it's
been
president trump has been impeached for
the second time that's a first for any
sitting president
while twitter youtube and facebook have
all suspended
his accounts many of his followers then
moved to parlor
an alternative social media platform but
apple and google quickly removed parlor
from their app stores
and amazon web services removed parlour
from its
cloud effectively that deleted the
platform
from the internet silicon valley has
never quite flexed its muscles in this
way before
which is why it is on this week's
spectator cover
i'm joined again by amber athe the
uh spectators washington editor and also
by peter greenberger
former head of political advertising at
twitter
and google peter let me come to you
first you once said that you were proud
of twitter's
uh commitment to free speech are you
still proud of it
i am i am proud of of what the company
has created over the last decade or so
creating a platform where people from
all walks of life whether you're an
elected official or
an everyday citizen can have your voice
heard
and to be able to read and comment on
and
and share uh what other people are
saying
i am also proud of what they've done
just recently i don't think this is
something they took lightly i don't
think this is something they ever wanted
to do
and as jack dorsey has said just
recently
he sees this as a failure actually on
their part
that they weren't able to maintain a
healthy conversation i disagree
i think it's a larger societal an
electoral and even
governmental failure but still i think
their hand was forced
but are you comfortable with the idea
that who should be on twitter or
facebook or others
uh can be decided by a couple of
billionaires in silicon valley i i
recognize
again this is not ideal it's not a place
where we wanted to be or where these
companies wanted to be but i think
what you have to understand is that this
is not necessarily
a question of the first amendment or a
question of free speech it's it's a
question of choice
and ultimately these companies made the
choice that they no longer wanted to
assist in the dissemination or the
hosting
of information that they saw as first of
all false as misinformation but also as
dangerous
and which which certainly led to uh in
large part led to
what happened at the u.s capitol on
wednesday so mr trump has been
suspended we think uh for life um
because he was seen by them to be
inciting violence leading to these
appalling scenes in capitol hill
but on twitter there is still a hashtag
kill trump
and a hashtag assassinate trump and one
of the tweets that goes with that
hashtag
tag is someone take this clown are you
mr trump
take him out now this is all still on
twitter
why if it violates their terms and
conditions they should bring it down and
i
certainly haven't read or can't i can't
defend every tweet but they
have terms and conditions which up until
recently
there was this carve out uh under the
under under the newsworthiness label for
heads of state to be able to tweet
pretty much what they wanted and i
as you mentioned i had defended that for
many years when i worked there
and when i left i think it is most times
better to know what your leader is
thinking than to have to guess
uh and in fact we now are in that
position where we hear that he is
raging around an empty west wing and
we're not quite sure what's on his mind
perhaps it would be better to know but i
will say his behavior has improved
markedly
now that he has lost his favorite toy it
i'm not i mean there is a case against
what twitter
and others have done but that's not the
case i'm putting to you it's the
consistency
it's the criteria i mean some people
will find it strange that mr trump
has been banned for life from twitter
but the ayatollah in iran is still able
to tweet his bile against israel
talking about how the regime will perish
i think what they've done with trump
however now opens
the door for them to take further action
which again is not where they wanted to
be
but now that they have taken this very
very dramatic important step i think
they can look
harder at the policies that they've had
again the terms and conditions have been
that
ordinary users you and i cannot use the
platform to threaten violence
uh or or incite violence against other
people
foreign leaders however have been able
to tweet pretty much what they want
this is what crossed the line should it
have been uh
you know the khomeini should have been
somebody else perhaps
but this is the time when they felt they
had to make the decision i will say that
they there has always been this
complaint that it falls harder on
certain segments
the fact is going away from from iran
back to the united states conservatives
in particular feel like
they're being picked on when you look at
who's violating the terms and conditions
it's one side violating the terms and
conditions at a much higher rate than
the other side
those are the accounts that have been
taken hold on let's have a look at that
because after
we know that black lives matter use
twitter and facebook to organize
uh their demonstrations many of which
ended in riot and violence
in portland and seattle not one of them
was closed down
there's a twitter account called pigs in
a blanket
fry them like bacon pigs in a blanket
prime like bacon's referring to the
police it's a call
to kill police that twitter account is
still
up as well people can incite violence
and twitter has done
nothing about it i i would disagree
again i would say on the main
it's it's a bit like whack-a-mole there
are millions of accounts tweeting out
millions of pieces of information every
day when things are flagged
and things clearly violate the terms and
conditions they make an effort to take
them down
again there's been this accusation that
it's based on partisanship
when studies have been done they have
seen that more people are making
violations on the right there is a
segment of the population in the united
states
that believes things that are that are
completely
untrue and it's because the leaders of
the country the elected officials of the
country and some main conservative
outlets
peddle in this lunacy even just the
other day you had
a member of congress refused to admit
who's going to be the next president or
that he was elected rightfully
we had an election it was as transparent
as every other election we've ever had
and yet for some reason certain members
of the government refuse to acknowledge
it and they're inciting this madness
so there are different levels i think of
misinformation
and it's hard to pinpoint we had a
justice potter here who said
uh uh when defining something else i'll
know it when i see it
and i think finally twitter decided they
knew it when they saw it
information that they no longer wanted
to host on their platform can you give
any examples of
uh the black lives matter uh
organizers uh using social media
to organize what became violent protests
can you give any examples of them
being taken down i don't have them handy
i'm sure they did take down
uh organizations and people that have
excited violence on the other side
the fact is though that they haven't
incited this type of violence it's just
a mistruth
and this uh comparison black lives
matter have not incited any violence
not not in a not not in in his directive
fashion as the president of knights
president of the united states giving a
speech to what essentially was an angry
mob and directing them to the united
states capital
people marched in the streets to provide
rights for people that have not
had equal rights in this country for 400
years
and that's just a different matter so
the people who
have caused the consistent violence
in seattle and in portland are in a
different category from those who caused
the violence in capitol hill last week
i i condemn all violence as everyone has
but yes i would put it in a different
category actually
but either way twitter needs to enforce
their rules equally and i think now that
they've taken this action against the
president
they will take a harder look at not only
other foreign other leaders other
people in power but also other
organizations who use the platform
was it right to ban links
uh to the new york post story about
hunter biden
that was a very difficult uh choice for
them to make and
and that that's something that i think
people can certainly debate freely i
think that the company themselves
uh took a step back from that and and
and recognized that maybe that was not
the best decision that they made
but that's a hard question for them to
answer and i think that's what all these
social media companies and news
organizations have to answer for
what i'll say is that we have all
learned a lot from 2016. there were
cable networks who aired then candidate
trump's
speak rally speeches from start to
finish well before he was a front-runner
because it made great tv now when he is
speaking at the lectern in the white
house press briefing room
there are cable networks that will go
away from him if he starts
speaking miss troops that's mistruths
that's a remarkable change
similarly the social media companies
would
publish and post and share anything and
everything related to the election
under the guise of sticking to freedom
of expression four or five years
ago now they're putting some limits on
that so do you allow stories to spread
that are blatantly mistrue is the first
question
but of course a very important question
as you raise is
who who's the arbiter of truth and these
companies have said that they do not
want to be the arbiter of truth
but the problem is there is no arbiter
of truth and that's what we're figuring
out
uh even if you're an elected official it
turns out you can say whatever
helps you raise money and grift off your
offer your supporters
in a sense it's an issue of who god's
the guardians and i'll come back to that
uh in a minute let me bring amber in now
surely it's only right that companies
like twitter
and facebook and others they
should not have an obligation to publish
disinformation and incitement to
violence
yeah i think that's a fair statement
however the problem with what they did
to the president
is that they actually punished him for
behavior that occurred off of the
platform and peter tassley admitted this
in one of his answers to you andrew
when trump was actually removed from
twitter they cited two
specific tweets that he had sent that
occurred after
the capitol riot and claimed that he was
inciting further violence but they had
read that incitement into the tweet it
wasn't actually there
the first one that they had a problem
with was him saying that he still
believed the election was stolen
and the second one is and i think this
quote is pretty accurate although
i'm paraphrasing slightly for those who
have been asking
i will not be attending the inauguration
on january 20th
that was the second tweet from the
president that they cited as
incitement of violence if you can be
punished for things that you say or
behavior that you engage in off of the
platform then that means the terms of
service
of these various social media platforms
are phony
well i was going to say if if you can't
take into account real life events
then i'm not sure we want anyone over
there trying to arbiter or or divine the
the interpretation of what donald
trump's tweets are
it was very clear that he continues to
perpetuate
this idea that he won this election in a
huge landslide and it's being stolen
from him and his fellow patriots
that's ludicrous he lost the election
everybody knows he lost the election
i'm almost a little bit worried thinking
that maybe he doesn't know i it was
either he's
completely delusional he might be the
one that doesn't know
he might be which i don't know what's
scarier uh if this is a
he really believes this stuff b he was
just playing a game to raise money and
he doesn't like to lose
uh or or c he really was plotting
something more nefarious right and i
think it's probably a combination of all
three
but it's very clear what he's doing and
amber we knew where this would go
if you're part of a doomsday cult that
says january 15th the world is going to
end
the sun rises on january 16th what does
everybody do
who has spent the last 6 12 24
48 months preparing for the end of the
world it's not coming
bynum will be inaugurated on january
20th we've always known that
and for some reason a sizable percentage
of the american population
refuses to believe that reality because
they're being egged on
by by by by our leadership
frankly amber well if you knew that this
was going to happen then why did these
social media companies not ban the
president sooner why is there
retroactive action being taken
and i would also ask why there are
multiple tweets from democratic
officials that remain up
after the 2016 election where they were
questioning whether or not that
election was legitimate nancy pelosi has
a tweet from 2017 for example
where she says that this election was
not legitimate and that the president is
not the true president
so why is one of those inciting violence
and the other is not
well i think you've just answered your
question one of them did not incite
violence and the other one did first of
all
and second of all tweets from the
president that led to his suspension
were tweets that were characterized as
the having the potential to incite
violence
after a violent event had occurred in
the same way you could read the same
thing into pelosi's tweet
there were riots all over dc where
people were smashing store windows
and burning down the city during trump's
2016 inauguration
and pelosi was questioning the election
in 2017.
so why was hers not given the same
characterization as the presidents
because well i again i'll disagree and
i'll say hindsight's 2020
and there have not been mobs of people
roaming the streets and certainly not
breaching
the the sacred grounds of the u.s
capitol arguing that nancy pelosi or her
party should be
uh in charge of the white house that it
just didn't happen and this kind of both
sides ism
uh that we've gotten accustomed to i
think it hopefully also
uh will will will die a death here but
i'll also note that in october 19th
i did write a piece in the washington
post calling for
facebook and twitter to mute the
president i considered calling on them
to mute
both the president and joe biden but i'm
not sure anybody is
reading joe biden's tweets as closely as
they're reading the president's they're
not quite as interesting
but they're also not inciting this type
of of nonsense and ignorance and
violence out in the country so
i would just disagree with with on the
face that i think that
uh what people said about the
presidential election in 2016 first of
all there were investigations about it
so there was a
at least enough of it there there uh
where people did suspect that there was
some things going on that were not
above level but i'd also say that there
was not violence there hasn't been
violence uh certainly not to this degree
i think what does concern people peter
though is the sense of unaccountable
power
whether you agree with what twitter has
done whether you think it's biased that
it tends to go for
those on the right rather than the left
the bigger issue is unaccountable power
particularly when they seem to act in
concert i mean these are
these are companies far bigger than the
oil
the railways the steel the robber barons
at the end of the 19th century in
america
they've got much more money and much
more influence and yet
twitter bans trump for life and you've
given the reason why and incitement to
violence is a
is something that has there's not a
right to that uh
in free speech but
trump's people then say all right we're
going to move to parlor and we can do
stuff there
and then immediately the rest of big
tech
closes that down as well the apps are
you cannot get either from google or
from apple
and amazon says we ain't hosting you
anymore
that's a cartel in america
cartels are illegal
think that's something that the new
congress both sides
have an interest in and the power of big
tech and whether
uh whether they're using that power
correctly or whether they should have
that much power
is something that should be looked into
and i have no doubt that it will be
investigated
ironically though should section 230 for
instance which provides these platforms
with
the the protection not to be liable for
everything
that people post ironically you remove
section 230
and parlor and gab are gone in 30
seconds i don't think they
they want to be held liable for the
information that's on those platforms
and they'll learn how hard a job this is
to try to monitor it so so that's a
problem
and i and i hear your point when the
platform
said look we're not a newspaper we're
not i mean if we publish in the
spectator
an incitement to violence or or
something that's libelous or defamatory
or whatever
we are subject to the full force of the
law can cost us a lot of money
editor in some circumstances could go to
jail
the the social media platform said we're
not publishers
we're just a platform we're a neutral
platform
and so therefore we're not responsible
for what appears
but suddenly mr dorsey and mr zuckerberg
are saying actually we are responsible
that's why we're taking the president
down because he's inciting
violence it's why we are closing down
parlor
because it's full of insidious toxic
stuff
the moment you do that you need to be
regulated and subject to the law of the
land
i i'll quote uh senator mitt romney who
at one point
was looked upon favorably by the
republican party i'm not sure he is
by everybody anymore but he mentioned
that corporations are people in a
different context
corporations are people in that they are
made up of people making decisions
want to talk about the first amendment
the first amendment means being able to
say what you want
and do business with whom you'd like to
do business with so ultimately this was
a choice
i i i it is am i comfortable they all
acted in concert
no i'm not but i can say that my guess
is it's more about
you know one person making a decision
everybody else looking around and saying
those guys don't seem to want to do
business with people trafficking in
in conspiracy theories nonsense lies and
violence
you know what we don't have to either
and in fact we may end up being liable
for it depending what happens in the
next congress so
the power of the tech companies must be
looked into i think
even they have called for zuckerberg you
mentioned he has called for regulation
he doesn't want to be put in this
position
uh in his own words let me go back to
amber
i mean don't don't the republicans only
have themself
uh to blame they have been in a position
amber for the past four years
to do something about this uh maybe to
take a leap
out of teddy roosevelt's book he was a
republican president
admittedly rather different more
distinguished president than mr trump
but he was of the fortune along with
mckinley
as well of do of bringing in what became
the anti-trust legislation against the
robber barons in america
but amber the republicans did nothing
about this when they had the chance to
do it
you're exactly right andrew this is a
major failure of the republican party
there were whispers
about things like anti-trust regulation
or section 230 reform
by some members of the republican party
notably senator josh hawley
congressman matt gates but outside of
just a few republicans this was not
something that was very popular the cry
from
the free market conservatives was that
these are private companies and
therefore
they get to decide who is allowed on
their platforms but when these companies
start acting in coordination with one
another
and control so much of the internet that
they can summarily ban a competitor
then that's when you start to get into
an anti-trust situation
and in fact jack dorsey said in his
statement
explaining the banning of the president
from multiple platforms yesterday by
claiming that they had not acted in
coordination with one another
however twitter did say from their
public policy team
that when they were looking at
misinformation and the spread of
misinformation in the ugandan election
that they had all acted in coordination
i can't think of a better case that a
company would make against its own
monopolistic behavior
than what twitter admitted to just a
couple of days ago
peter let me finish with with you uh
the the democrats at the moment they now
control the white house
they've got a casting vote majority in
the senate they've got a smallish
majority
in the house but they're in charge of
these three key parts
of government they must think that so
far
the big tech people have censored those
that they think should have been
censored they're on the
way on the opposite side of the aisle
sometimes way out on the far
right bit of the aisle will they have an
appetite to do anything about
big tech in the next couple of years
i think they will i mean certainly um
senator warren
uh has been very vocal on this was very
vocal on this during the campaign
uh as well as some other other more left
of center democrats in the senate in the
house
i think there are concerns to be raised
this is not something that we've seen
you know in a while in the united states
at least since we last took antitrust
action these are very very large very
powerful companies
who have gotten to a point where they
have such influence that i think that
the government should
take a look and and i think that that
will happen um
really regardless of who's in power i
think there's appetite on both sides now
but
you know you mentioned andrew when you
asked emperor uh do the republicans have
themselves to blame
uh and in this case i think the answer
is yes the republicans do have
themselves to blame
they have not been a responsible
political party
and there's a reason why their base has
become
unhinged from reality and they have a
responsibility
to tell the truth to their base to stop
the big lie
and hopefully that will improve the
situation in society
because ultimately social media is a
mirror of society
it's only going to be as good or as
truthful or as valuable as the people
who are posting
on it all right peter we'll leave it
there uh peter and amber thank you so
much for joining us i know it's early
where you are
in the morning and we're grateful for
your time and your contributions thank
you both
[Music]
you